In a shocking development,
conservative air horn
and thinking man's
swamp thing, Bill O'Reilly,
has been fired by Fox News.
-(cheers and applause)
-Yeah! Yeah!
-Yeah!
-(chanting and whooping)
Big fans of that.
This comes amid revelations
that the network paid out
multi millions
to settle multiple
sexual harassment suits
involving
the famously-furious host.
When he's not
aimlessly shouting
and harassing woman
who work for him,
O'Reilly moonlights
as the best-selling author of
Killing Lincoln,
Killing Kennedy
and Killing Reagan.
His next book will be
Killing My Own Career.
(applause and cheering)
Bill's already transitioning
from the no-spin zone
to the no-job zone.
On vacation today, he was
photographed meeting the pope.
(laughter)
Ugh! Guys...
Guys, I wonder
if he had anything to confess.
I don't know.
Think about it.
I mean, listen,
if you get fired for a raft
of sexual harassment charges,
you can always find a job
in the Catholic Church.
Hey-oh!
-(applause and cheering)
-Come on, you guys.
Hey-oh!
-That's wrong.
-Comedians, with the recent...
Four years of Catholic
high school.
Four years. Four years,
Catholic high school.
With the recent departures
of O'Reilly and Megyn Kelly,
it seems like the conservative
news network is either trying
to get rid of every Irish person
who works there,
or undergoing major changes.
What is next for Fox News?
Marcella.
I don't know, Chris, but it will
definitely be racist as (bleep).
HARDWICK:
All right. Points.
-(applause and cheering)
-Yeah!
-Chris.
-They'll use all these disasters
to justify never
hiring women again
because if they weren't around,
none of this (bleep)
would have happened.
-HARDWICK: All right, points.
-(laughter, applause)
-That's their words, not mine.
-That's their... yeah.
-I like how you had to make the
clarification. -Oh, yeah, yeah.
Oh, that's them. That's not me.
I'm not saying...
-Yeah.
-That's not me. I love my mama.
HARDWICK:
Ross Mar... Ross Marquand.
(imitating Clooney): Uh,
they're gonna get George Clooney
to come in there and do
The Fantastic Mr. Fox News.
-(laughter) -HARDWICK: Oh,
that's fantastic. Oh, I wonder
if George Clooney were here
right now what he would say.
-Well, I just did that.
-Oh, there we go. -(laughter)